I'm going to focus on the mosanitizumab and polatizumab vedotin for relapsed refractory
diffused B-cell lymphomas.
These are my financial disclosures.
So as the audience is aware, mosanitizumab is CD3-CD20 targeting bispecific T-cell engager
antibody, and it is approved for follicular lymphoma in the third-line settings.
In addition, polatizumab vedotin is an antibody drug conjugate targeting CD79B, and it's
approved in the front-line setting for DLBCL and also in the relapsed settings.
So the combination, which was thought to be synergistic, and also the polatizumab is thought
to increase the expiration of CD20 and potentiating the effect of mosanitizumab for lymphoma cell
killing.
So that was the rationale for doing this phase 2 trial.
Patients with relapsed large B-cell lymphoma receiving one prior lines of therapies, including
CD20 targeting treatment.
They were eligible.
Patients who were ineligible for stem cell transplant were enrolled in this trial.
The study design included intravenous mosanitizumab in the step of fashion in the first cycle
and subsequently every three weeks for a total of 17 cycles.
Patients who achieve CR at cycle 8 can stop treatment at that moment, but patients who had
partial remission at cycle 8 can finish a total of 17 cycles.
Polatizumab was given intravenously at every three weeks.
at every three weeks interval for a total of six cycles. The trial did not require any mandatory
hospitalization for CRS management, sorry, for CRS monitoring. So in the phase two portion,
a total of 98 patients were enrolled. Majority of the patients had deep field large B-cell lymphoma
and close to 60% of patients had germinal center origin as a cell of origin. Median lines of
prior therapy were true. One-third of patients received prior CAR-T-cell therapy and half of
the patients had primary refractory disease. The efficacy results for three years of follow-up
results were presented at ASH last year and the complete response rates, as you can see,
is 50% among all 98 patients, but also in patients who had primary refractory disease, CRS were 44%.
Patients who had prior CAR-T-cell therapy, 50%.
And refractory to prior CAR-T-cell therapy, the CRS were 42%.
Now, moving on to the overall response rates, the manuscript was indeed published a few years ago
in the Nature Medicine Journal, and it also showed that overall response rates and complete response
rates, they were seen across all subgroups. The three years follow-up results, which were
presented at ASH, showed that median duration of response was 24 months on the left side of the
upper plot.
Among patients who had CAR-T-cell therapy, median duration of response was close to four years,
showing that this combination can provide durable remissions. The median duration of complete
response was close to four years among all patient populations, and patients who had CAR-T-cell
therapy, median duration of complete response rate was close to four years. So pretty much
patients who respond to this combination, they can derive durable remissions, and there are very few
late recurrences noted.
Progression-free survival at three years was approximately 30%, but among those patients who received
CAR-T-cell therapy, three-year progression-free survival was approximately 40%. Three-year
overall survival was 42% among all patient population, and the survival was 44% among CAR-T-cell
therapy recipient patients.
The CRS rates are very important to analyze here. The rate of cytokine release syndrome was close to 19
patients, and a majority of CRS were mild, and mild grade 1 and grade 2. Median time to onset of CRS was
one day after the last dose, and the duration was two doses. As you can see, all CRS were reversible
with the help of supportive treatment.
ICANN's rates were 5%.
The other advantage was that the CRS rate was very low, and the duration was two doses. The CRS rate was
adverse events of interest were grade 3 for neutropenia, 20%, and grade 3 for serious
infections, which were 9%. So overall, this combination has manageable safety profile in
the relapsed large cell lymphoma settings. Now, moving on to the next step, based on this exciting
phase 2 data, which we participated, the company went on to perform phase 3 trial, which was
mucinotuzumab-polartuzumab comparing to R-GEMOX, which was a phase 3 Sunmo trial. The results were
presented at ICML last year and published in JCO last year. So I'll quickly go over with those
data as well. The study's design was the same as phase 2. Patients with relapsed large cell
lymphoma receiving one prior line subtherapies were randomized 2 to 1 to outpatient subcutaneous
mucinotuzumab 8 cycles and 6 cycles of polartuzumab intravenously.
These were the results of the trial. The results were presented at ICML last year and published in JCO last year.
The other control group was R-GEMOX, and patients received R-GEMOX in the standard fashion for a
total of 8 cycles. A total of approximately 200 patients were enrolled in this study,
138 in the mucin and pola, and 70 patients in R-GEMOX. Median age was 63 years, approximately 63
years in both age groups. Majority of the patients had B-cell lymphoma. Median lines of prior lines
of therapies were 2, and approximately 57 to 60 percent of patients had primary refractory disease.
So the primary endpoint was progression-free survival, and as you can see with the green
curve, which represents mucin and polartuzumab-vedotin combination, mucin and polan
significantly improved progression-free survival compared to R-GEMOX with a hazard ratio of 0.41.
At 18 months, progression-free survival was 39 percent with the combination versus for
14 percent in the R-GEMOX group. The subgroup analysis showed that the combination improved
PFS in all the important subgroups, including relapse and refractory settings, second line
versus third line plus settings. Importantly, the combination had higher rate of complete
remission rates, 51 percent, which is what we observed in the phase 2 settings, but the CRS
were essentially double than the current R-GEMOX standard of care chemotherapy arm.
Complete responses were durable at 18 months. Duration of complete response was 65 percent with
the combination versus 44 percent in the R-GEMOX arm, and the median duration of complete response
in the mucin and polartuzumab did not reach. The side effects were essentially the same what we
observed in the phase 2 component, and also the R-GEMOX side effects were also the similar
in what we expect. So fixed duration, mucin and polartuzumab,
has demonstrated high and clinically meaningful responses in relapse-refractory large base cell
lymphoma in both phase 2 and phase 3 SUNMO trial. The safety profile supports this use for outpatient
care, and mucin and polartuzumab offers a fixed duration outpatient regimen for patients with
relapse-refractory large base cell lymphoma in transplant-ineligible comorbid or post-carticel
therapy settings. Thank you so much.